[Music]
taking a run down your favorite black
diamond usually requires your most
undivided attention but if you've got a
second to divert your eyes from the
slopes Recon Instruments has a pretty
cool gadget for you it's called the mod
live and it's a fiber optics display
which actually snaps into a pair of
snowboard goggles so you can keep track
of things like how fast you're going
down the slope the height of your jobs
the distance of your jumps as well as
your route map while you're on the
mountain it's all controlled via this
little armband controller which and go
around your arm or can actually go up on
your goggles band itself and the mod
live also has full Android phone
functionality so while you're on the
slopes you can actually do things like
take your incoming phone calls or see
who's calling you can look at your text
messages and send back pre-programmed
auto replies as well as manage your
music playlists the mod live is
available everywhere right now and
retails for $400
[Applause]
you